hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the comic and
ethics book eight Aristotle provides a
famous treatment of friendship which
distinguishes friendships into three
main categories one of which is
friendship in terms of the good or
virtue another which is friendship in
terms of usefulness in another one the
one that we're going to look at here is
in terms of pleasure where pleasure
provides the basis for the ongoing
friendship for the relationship for why
the people are spending time with each
other and why they are wishing well or
wishing good towards each other we've
discussed and distinguished these these
three types of friendship in another
core concept video and this one though I
want to concentrate specifically on what
is distinctive about a friendship in
terms of pleasure and this is one that
all of us are I hope familiar with we
may not necessarily be familiar with
friendship in terms of virtue Arizona
says that those are less common and
there's a lot more demanded for those
although they are the paradigm for
friendship per se but all of us I think
have had some friendships that involve
pleasure and then perhaps we don't have
those friendships anymore in part
because
these are not as long lasting as the
other types of friendships but they're
easier to come by and they are much more
common so what is going on in a
friendship in terms of pleasure there is
mutual affection or affection towards
each other what aerosol calls aunty
fillets I on team meeting you know in
return and fill a sty being the verb for
you know feeling off or a friendship for
relationship few aim is actually the
infinitive of the active this is this is
a different form of it in any case
they're feeling something towards each
other reciprocally on account of
pleasure something that we experience in
many different ways there's a wide range
of pleasures that we can experience you
know ranging from those of sexuality to
laying in the Sun getting massages you
know watching TV together that's a
pleasant activity of course air assault
in that TV but they had spectacles
eating meals together drinking together
all sorts of other things driving around
some people are into road trips we can
talk about all these different
possibilities and because we have such a
wide range of pleasures there's a lot of
different ways in which we could in fact
be friends with each other so there are
their friends with each other on account
of the pleasure not for who they are
there's something that is more
superficial about this kind of
friendship presumably it's not purely
accidental that these people happen to
be pleasant to each other it has to do
something that is in transit to them but
you're not loving or are being friends
with the other person for their own sake
in is kind of friendship you're friends
with them because they provide you with
like it but here being pleasant for the
person who is experiencing the pleasure
so if somebody isn't Pleasant then you
can't be friends with it
on this sort of account you know if
you're not a virtuous person and you
don't like what the virtuous person does
because of them being virtuous you can't
be friends with them in terms of virtue
to certainly but you can't be friends
with them also in terms of pleasure
because you don't enjoy it at that sort
of thing and we can talk about people
you know changing their pleasures over
time that's one reason why these kinds
of friendships are a little bit less
lasting so that's a good point to move
to this other key idea these sorts of
friendships they're not as durable as
friendships per se friendships in terms
of virtue they didn't cool that is they
can you know become less of a friendship
or they can even break up why because
our pleasure that the amount of pleasure
that we derive from the other person or
the activities that we engage in with
them might Wayne over time or might even
disappear or or or you know something
like that so when somebody for example
who we enjoy playing with on a sports
team and you know we engage in the
physical activity we also engage in some
competitiveness right all those sorts of
things that go into making sports fun
for us when they need no longer can
provide that that's sort of thing let's
say they get injured you know we will
still hang out with them and go to the
hospital room but we might not stay
friends with them if they're no longer
in the league and Aristotle says that's
that's understandable for this type of
friendship we don't have to pretend that
it's something that it isn't online wise
the very common in erotic or romantic
relationships people are initially very
attracted to each other gain a lot of
pleasure from being in each other's
company and then after that that begins
to wane things cool off and they're no
longer driving as much enjoyment they
may actually go the other way and find
each other's presence painful in certain
respects Aristotle says that if
that kind of friendship it's natural for
that to break up and it's actually kind
of a mistake to try to impose the other
type of friendship on it and somehow
make it last like that if it's going to
last you have to find other pleasures or
you have to find some way to revive the
pleasure or to you know perhaps you can
spend time remembering the pleasure that
it's all can be pleasant but there's a
lot of other examples we could talk
about as well somebody who enjoys eating
with another person let's say we have
two people who are our gourmets right
they spend a lot of time savoring
particular dishes and going places one
of them suddenly loses their income and
can no longer go to the restaurants well
then they're probably not going to be a
particularly good company or you know
let's say they lose their sense of taste
or they are no longer interested in that
because they want to spend all their
time reading philosophy instead and most
of the Philosopher's seem to be downtown
groom on these right there would be an
example of a friendship then at wings
and very interestingly i think is
something we can all relate to Aristotle
says young people are particularly prone
to this kind of friendship who isn't
prone to this coverage of old people
because old people aren't very pleasant
Egypt maybe that Aristotle is drawing a
bit of how the culture of his own time
but you know the idea is that old people
aren't so fun to look at their that's a
fun few with you can't do as much with
them but but young people you know
they're full of energy they have the
blush of youth their whole lives ahead
of them so they're much more fun to be
with and the thing is young people also
have fully developed so they are very
prone to this kept friendship they're
also very prone to the mistake of
thinking that this kind of friendship
turns into best friends forever and
there's a lot of disappointments that
happen in youth and adolescence because
of this aren't there as peoples you know
you might say manifold of pleasures
change from year to year to year you
might leave your old friends behind you
no longer listen to the same music
you're no longer get into the same
bullocks you no longer like seeing
movies you're no longer interested in
the same sort of discussion topics you
don't want to play the sort of saints or
games with each other those are all ways
in which those kinds of friendships can
and probably should according to
Aristotle dissolve because it's quite a
you know understandable romantic or
erotic relationships are very often this
type of friendship although there can be
some where it's more a friendship of
utility or a mixed relationship as we'll
talk about later but quite often when we
think about romantic relationships what
we are thinking about is something that
aerosol would say is a friendship based
on unpleasant why do you want to hang
out with that person why do you want to
you know make out with them have sex
with them why do you want to do all
these sorts of things because it's
pleasant why did that emit not somebody
else because the other person isn't as
pleasant as this person is or perhaps
the other person is actually not
pleasant at all but rather beautiful to
you right and we could we could mix in
all these other sorts of things he also
says to these kind of coincide young
people are not only prone to this kind
of friendship young people are also very
often driven by erotic desire and you
know I think there's probably something
to that you know we talked about raging
hormones for example now what makes this
kind of friendship work what makes it
lasting here's where Arizona that
something really interesting to say
about this he says it's most lasting
when the friends derive pleasure from
the same thing and not so much directly
in an exchange from each other so
romantic or erotic relationships are by
their very nature if they're their
friendships a pleasure not all that
durable why because the reasons why we
find people attractive and therefore
when we're in there
their company enjoy it or pleasant
change over time right our bodies age
what what sort of thing appealed to us
when we were young may not appeal to us
the same way when we're old people get
together and at first they seemed
brilliant and you know just full of all
sorts of new vistas of things that
you've never experienced or heard about
and then after a while you know it
becomes the opposite this is a very
common set of issues and you know men's
and women's magazines devote a lot of
articles to this every month right
Aristotle is saying well that's because
they're not actually friends in pleasure
because they enjoy the same thing
they're enjoying something that they're
getting from each other and so when they
can't provide that something one of them
on one part the other on the other part
the friendship is likely to dissolve by
contrast if you enjoy watching movies
and that remains the same you and that
friend who you watch movies with both of
whom it you know derive some sort of
enjoyment in that and also derive
enjoyment perhaps by talking with each
other and spending time with each other
on that is more likely to last so
interestingly when the friendship is
based not so much on the person but on
what you do with that person Arizona is
the example of people who are we who
have a good sense of humor they enjoy
spending time with each other but it's
not an exchange the way that's going on
with romantic relationships there
there's a relation to something else it
could be of course that they're they
really just enjoy making fun of other
people are bullying other people
although that would not be the same
thing as having that wittiness on air
part that would be something quite
different so that's an interesting point
another thing that's important to note
with this kind of friendship is it's not
a moral friendship in the sense that it
requires both partners to be a high
moral character it's possible to be
friends with a bad person on account of
the pleasure that they bring this
happens an awful lot and VIN romantic
relationships right okay we make movies
we make lifetime dramas we make all
sorts of you know romance novels and
stuff precisely that it's possible for
good people to be friends with each
other is even possible for bad people to
be friends with each other and Aristotle
says something really quite quite funny
about this he says they have people can
be friends in terms of pleasure because
when they're doing that they're not
paying attention to who these the person
actually is if they were concerned with
the the you know the who the unit the
other person is their character they
wouldn't like spending time with each
other but the fact that they old you
know like drinking together or eating
together or you know I'm going to the
Opera or whatever makes it possible for
them to have this kind of friendship not
bad people will typically screw each
other over sooner or later so that
introduces another wrinkle into this but
even with good people it's not expected
that this kind of friendship would
necessarily have to go on forever this
kind of friendship is more common it's
it's something I think like I said
before most of us if not all of us
experience and probably have a number of
friendships at any given time you may
possibly have something like this online
where is it's much more difficult to do
so with the friendship in terms of
virtue you know when we belong to
communities or things along those lines
and this is an important type of
relationship Harris level is not
knocking it but it does want us to fully
understand what it is